good evening members
officers and members of the public and
welcome to this joint transportation
board 22 march 2022
as usual i'll start with housekeeping if
the fire alarm is activated please
forget the offices via the stairs
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the lifts assembly in hall is
square on the green and office will
assist you and advise when it is deemed
safe to return to the chamber
could everyone present please ensure
that mobile phones are switched to
silent that they are not used to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have the image captured i urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if they are children
present does anyone intend to film thank
you
apologies for absence i have apologies
from council bings and council lewis
item agenda item two declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest
no thank you
i agenda item three minutes of the
previous meeting
do members agree that the minutes the
joint transportation board meeting held
on the 14th of december 2021 be approved
and signed as a correct record
mayor have a proposal please
council crew brown seconda
council scoby thank you very much
do members agree
thank you
agenda item 4 is a highway works program
2021
22 and 2022 23
as we don't have a kcc officer present
any questions or comments will be
recorded and passed on to the relevant
offices
do members have any questions or
comments on the report please
council brown yeah as uh
councillor binks cannot make it tonight
uh i've been asked
to ask a few questions
throughout the proceedings but
yeah a gender item for appendix i
kcc maintain public rights away but can
tdc confirm if they clean them all if
not can we have a list of which ones
they don't do
thank you i think we need to have that
answer
um
get back to your answer because we
obviously haven't got that answer
so we will have to get back to you on
that program thank you
so tonks
council yates thank you chair um it was
just a question on page four
new cross street is having its foot
footway reconstruction
and as part of that
um the road has changed back to its
original direction
as part of this old town traffic
management i'm just wondering if there's
any plans um to change that following
the completion of the works
thank you
unfortunately once again i haven't got
an answer for you because we haven't got
an officer here with us
but james would have taken that down and
we will get back to you that one thank
you
there's a question i just wonder why
there's no nobody from kcc present if we
we can turn up why can't they
well unfortunately allegedly
the officer that would be here i won't
mention his name but you know he with
normally comes
at kcc they're still not allowing them
to come
face to face that is what we've been
told
so i can't we can't have faith because
we can't if we have that we kind of live
streaming
so we we can't have both
so unfortunately we can have an officer
here
thank you
all right this report is for information
so please can members note the report
thank you
agenda item 5 management act update i
call upon miss button director of
neighborhoods and to introduce reports
thank you very much chair so this is a
brief summary of the changes that are
coming into place um
on the 31st of may
2022 to the traffic management act it's
essentially a consolidation
of um all of our traffic orders and
regulations into the one act um just
which makes it very much easy for us to
enforce the biggest change um isn't to
do with us at tdc it's actually to do
with kcc um and i was asked by the vice
chair to just bring this report to to
summarise where we're at with that so
the biggest change to kcc is moving
traffic offense enforcement
so that's where you
um
compar where you park in box junctions
where you use bus lanes and you
shouldn't do that kind of moving traffic
enforcement we're not responsible for
that that is with kcc um they have to
apply to the secretary of state to be
given that power we and they are in the
process of doing that you've probably
read about this since i wrote this
report in the kent online so i'm kind of
probably
repeating everything you already know um
but they are looking at specific areas
to target to start with with enforcement
for moving traffic offences um
and they have made it
the the legislation has made it and the
guidance has made it very clear that not
all signs and markings will be enforced
and that they are only looking to
target problem locations
so i think
the thing that we've taken from that as
as tdc officers is if we have or become
aware of places where we know we have
ongoing issues with moving traffic um
or not moving as the case may be and we
will raise that with kcc and i think
that's something that we would encourage
others to do in order that we if we need
to we can become one of those hot spot
places
but yeah that's about it so i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you penny um
do members have any questions or
comments on the report please
council fellows
yeah thank you um
obviously you said it was this is all to
do with kcc and things they're bringing
in if you look at the legislative
changes uh
paragraph two two point five says in
summary thanks district council already
for the 31st of may we've made the
appropriate changes to penalty charge
notices so what
can just confirm what is tdc and what
his case is
so our changes are the the actual
on our fixed points notices you have to
have the correct legislation in order
for them to be enforceable and that
legislation changes so the the
bit for tdc is the consolidating so at
the moment we've got lots and lots of
different regulations they're all going
to be under the traffic management act
and that will be so our fixed penalty
notices literally are changing the title
at the top of them
and the appeals so it's just just so
that you're aware that we are all ready
for that and good to go so anything that
we serve on the 30th has to be
under one set of
regulations and it has to be followed
all the way through the process under
that set of regulations and anything
issued from the 31st onwards has to be
under the new regulations
thank you
so the problem area is that who's going
to choose those problem areas
sorry kcc are choosing those so are we
allowed to submit uh areas to them for
consideration because i know some areas
that could could do with
looking at sorry they haven't come to us
with any um suggestions have how they're
putting those places forward um but i
think it's at the moment they're at the
very start of the process so i think it
will be something that evolves over time
and i said we will be looking at
anything that we get to refer on to them
to make sure that they are aware of any
hot spots that we're aware of in fannie
can i make you aware of a potsdam
absolutely
you can email me
any other questions for members
council talks
yellow boxes who's going to enforce this
and the other question would be is are
you looking forward to the changes on
the 31st of may
because it sounds to me it can get more
complicated
thank you
it'll be kcc that enforces yellow boxes
in that respect and we are because it
won't be complicated it will actually
make it easier for us going forward
can i just reply on that kdc i'm part of
i'll give up
thank you councillor tongs any other
members have any questions please
no other questions
council crowbar you haven't got one no
okay
thank you for allowing me to speak
um
as a bay holder
me and several neighbours are having
problems with the parking team atlantic
council
now um
one
instance is the
after the june meeting
i spoke to vicky and another lady after
the
i think was a june joint transportation
board meeting and they were amazed that
the out of hours team did not have any
contact for the parking team and they
assured me that the parking team should
be available to the out of hours team if
needed
then we have
um
they also said on here that there's been
an issue we regarding bayesian in in our
road and the council sent a letter out
now that letter
come from
the parking office rebecca glazier now
that contains information that is
contradictory on there and against the
application
the um
the
the bays are there for the applicants
to parking
which as we all know the bays are for
any valid blue badge holder
so the parking office
again
confusing information
but size
now there's two sizes of bay there's a
normal bay in extended bay
now
according to tdc
that size varies depends who's on duty
because
um i've spoken to councillor saunders
and the parking office
we have submitted
lots and lots of photographs
of cars and vans that are half in the
bay
and the email reply
is unless the vehicle is half half the
vehicle is in the bay a ticket cannot be
issued
so therefore you can lose
a third each end of the bay
have no usable space or you can't even
get your vehicle out
parking teams not interested not
enforceable which i think is wrong if
the
guidance is a bay should be
6.6 meters long and 2.7 meters wide
then that should be the size it's
enforceable
if something is
five or ten centimeters over
ever
that's okay but when
they are
that much of the vehicle is in the bay
no enforcement and there were and there
was another vehicle behind it
uh on the other end i couldn't get a
scooter at the back i couldn't even get
the vehicle out the parking space reply
from the parking office we have looked
at the photos
and
it
and it clearly says that
unless half the vehicle is in the bay no
enforcement action is taken so i ask
for
guidance from you from the committee to
look again
uh at the
size of the bays that make the whole
bait enforceable
because at the moment is unclear
to certain traffic people i've spoken to
four officers
two would give tickets and two wouldn't
and this guidance has come from
rebecca glazier who i
now understand is uh
on maternity leave
i've done
two freedom of information requests 17th
of the 12th one to tcc
and one to kcc
regarding where these instructions are
that that say you can't give a ticket to
anything unless it's half it or more in
the bay
no such guidance exists
so okay mr wright you have had your
three meals over your females thank you
very much i don't know if we can get
response from either the officers here
okay yeah
you will get his support uh response in
the report okay
thank you very much
um councillor whitehead you would you
would like to speak under council
procedure 2012.01
three minutes please thank you
i'll do my very best thank you very much
councillor saunders
i'm here representing several residents
who consistently struggle not only with
the usage of their disabled parking bay
but also with the enforcement
surrounding those bays and the response
that we are currently giving when there
is an enforcement issue
it is these issues that led me to call
council to support personalised parking
permits for disabled residents
to ask for a full audit of our current
base and usage which i am glad to see is
happening and to promote and call for
personalized ways to be instituted at a
county level
as other councils already do this and as
it is the only way to resolve many of
these these issues it is to my mind
something that counts should be
wholeheartedly supporting and we at
district should be championing
in relation to the strategy before us i
ask all present to look at our duties in
relation to equality
at the heart of all our decision and
policy making is our public sector
equality duty and it is as follows
in all our decisions policies and
strategies we are bound to act in a way
that eliminates unlawful discrimination
harassment victimization and other
conduct prohibited by the equality act
2010
we are to advance equality of
opportunity between people who share a
protected characteristic and people who
do not share it and we are also bound to
foster good relations between people who
share a protected characteristic and
people who do not share it
in relation to disability equality
inequity within populations does not
mean providing the same provision or
level of support
to use a simple metaphor equity between
individuals is not guaranteed simply by
ensuring that everyone has allocated a
seat within a room
equity asks how that room can be
accessed and whether the allocated seats
are accessible to everyone
it asks if the seats are suitable for
everyone it asks if seats are needed
it asks whether any external issues
could prevent access to that room
it asks what each individual needs and
works to ensure that parity of access is
guaranteed
that life and living is equally enabled
by making adjustments when necessary
to follow this metaphor further we
currently have residents who often
cannot either access or exit this
metaphorical room and in reality their
own rooms
as a reflection of this disabled parking
is not simply a parking issue and cannot
be considered in the same way as our
standard enforcement approaches
it is an access to life issue
treating it as an ordinary issue of
enforcement diminishes the impact that
the loss of parking can have on a
disabled individual
if someone has been assessed as needing
proximity parking adjacent to their home
due to disability it's because that
access enables them to live their lives
in a way that many of us take for
granted
most of us can adjust to a parking spot
further down the road
those who have applied for and been
accepted for a disabled parking bay
cannot
and so the way we enforce and provide
for these spaces is in and of itself an
equality duty
being completely unable to move in and
out of your home due to inconsiderate
parking requires an extra response above
and beyond our standard response to
parking enforcement as it is not a
matter of inconvenience it's a matter of
quality of life and ensuring that we
meet our public sector equality duty
i do not believe that our strategy
currently meets that duty
to quote from page 37
reports of illegal parking can be made
out of office hours by emailing the
civil enforcement team and these will be
relayed to the civil enforcement
officers once office hours resume and
where necessary put in the diary for
further visits
our officers will issue a penalty charge
notice to a vehicle which is observed
parking and contravention of the
following
parked in a designated disabled person's
parking place without clearly displaying
a valid disabled person's badge
if no contravention is observed when our
officers attend we will not be able to
issue a penalty charge notice
what this strategy effectively says to
anyone reading it is that outside office
hours anyone can use a disabled parking
bay and remove an individual's right to
freedom of movement
it also informs anyone reading that that
as long as they remove their vehicle by
the time office hours resume there will
be no penalty for removing a vulnerable
individual's right to access
to properly fulfill our public sector
equality duty we have to offer a
response service to disabled individuals
in relation to their need to access and
it is not sufficient to effectively
allow significant periods of time where
disabled individuals rights to live in
equity are removed
are you almost there now council
whitehead
you've been over three minutes
um i beg the chairs discretion at this
point
i don't have that much longer to go i
promise thank you very much
we do need to have officers prioritize
attending in order to fulfill our duties
as a council
and we should not be putting in writing
that we cannot even guarantee attendance
when it involves something as
significant as equality's legislation
as mr wright mentioned in relation to
response guidance on what constitutes an
infringement also seems to vary with
residents being officially informed that
infringement has not occurred unless a
vehicle is parked over halfway into a
bay
any blockage or incursion to a disabled
bay can render it unusable due to the
potential need for ramps and general
access and if this is the guidance i
believe it needs to be altered to
recognize that any blockage needs to be
acted upon as any incursion into a
disabled bay can completely remove
access and this guidance potentially
means that two vehicles at either end of
a bay can completely obstruct a parking
spot with somehow no offence being
committed
i understand more than anyone the impact
of central cuts on services that we
provide but we are simply not fulfilling
our public sector equality duty if we
accept this strategy as it stands
it directly allows for the removal of
rights of disabled residents to access
and leave their properties and allows no
similar remedy if an infringement is not
directly observed by us when we don't
offer a response service and make no
guarantee of attendance and cannot be
contacted outside office hours
i am asking that all of the above issues
be addressed alongside the bay review
and that as a council we are updated on
progress towards personalized parking
permits
as this is to my mind the best way for
this issue to be addressed
i have huge respect for officers who are
having to work in an environment of
reduced funding and i accept fully that
this is an issue of capacity and likely
budget
but neither of those can or should
remove our equality's duty and as a
council we have a legal requirement to
promote equity and as it stands i'm
afraid this strategy does not do that
i thank you chair and i apologize for
overrunning
thank you councilwoman
to say as um holder we are happy to pay
an extra fee
if anything
is available we are
open to that idea
okay thank you
i called upon miss young
parking policy officer to introduce the
report
hello so thank you chair
we've written this report to try and
sort of summarize the process around
disabled persons parking base and what
we can do within our designated powers
for them base so as this report
summarizes um we have had communications
with disabled person base holders and we
have looked to at our processes and how
we can try to improve that so um
as the report outlines there is a
application process that a disabled
badge holder must go through in order to
get a disabled person's parking bay
outside of their residence
and um it is made clear on application
uh verbally over the phone when an
application pack is requested and
when the application pack is sent it is
said that any valid blue badge holder
may park within the bay and it is not a
guaranteed personal bag that is um
established from the start
um
there
in regards to um the
disabled person's parking bay's guidance
there may have been historic bays within
the district which do not match the
guidance set out by the british parking
association because they are historic
and this legislation was updated a few
years ago
there
they do say now that the bays must be a
minimum of 6.6 meters long
2.7 meters wide or three meters wide
we're placed in the center of the
carriageway so we are
shortly undertaking a disabled person's
parking place audit and this will aid us
in establishing any base which may not
be at that required length so that we
can move forward and make these changes
and we have been in conversation with
some bay holders within the district
already who have been experiencing
issues where their bay was not at that
6.6 metres in length and we have gone
ahead and extended the bay to assist
that them holders with their issues that
they've been experiencing and we will
continue to do so
um
enforcement of the disabled parking base
will come under the usual duties of our
civil enforcement officers um just to
give some
insight into how this will work our
officers will be allocated a what we
refer to as a beat so an area for their
shift and they will enforce and patrol
restrictions within this area during
their shift
we will have to prioritize and focus our
enforcement on dangerous bays busy areas
towns seafronts wla lines
and unfortunately we're not a response
service
and any reports of illegal parking made
to the civil enforcement office team are
recorded and communicated to the
officers on the ground during office
hours so if we re receive a telephone
call we will report that to our officers
there and then and where practical and
where possible they will
attend
if it's within their beat and their
shift
um we do have reports like like it says
here we you can make reports of illegal
parking out of office hours by emailing
the civil enforcement team
and these will be
relayed to the sibling enforcement
officers and if it's an ongoing issue
there will be appointments made like
points in the diary so that they are
aware that during the office hours when
the team aren't available to take them
phone calls that these experiences are
happening so that they can go and try
and enforce without having to be
prompted and we will try and anticipate
these areas and patrol these areas where
possible
um we unfortunately within the
legislation
we can only issue a penalty charge
notice to a vehicle which is observed
being parked in contravention by
um in contravention which is known as
code 40 and that is part in a designated
disabled person's parking place without
clearly displaying a valid disabled
person badge unfortunately because we
can only enforce what is in legislation
if no contravention is ever is observed
and there is no vehicle parked within
part of the bay unfortunately we are not
able to issue a penalty charge notice in
that instance
um so that's a summary of the report
there
thank you do members have any questions
or comments please
counselor crowbar news first for your
handout thank you
yeah this issue first come out mr ray
and the neighbor brought it to numerous
councillors attention as you'll be aware
chair
councillor binks informs me she is asked
for a chapter and verse summary of the
regulations nationally
and as they are interpreted by tdc
as you probably know these bays are
requested by individuals who pay for
them
however they are not guaranteed a
parking space
as any holder of a blue badge can
legitimately use
other vehicles as you've mentioned
cannot park in them and will be ticketed
as you previously said
the latest regulations tsr gd
2 2016 relax the size of the base
whilst the minimum width of 1.8 meters
is specified there is no longer a
maximum width
council of binks informs me
nor a minimum or maximum length the
intention is to allow traffic
authorities flexibility and determine
being the bay or parking space size
appropriate both for the intended
vehicle type and the surrounding street
environment
bay markings and parking space should be
of sufficient length and width to fully
accommodate the vehicles for which they
are intended
in cases where larger vehicles for
example 4x4 type vehicles cannot fit
fully within the marking it is
recommended that the traffic authorities
use discretion over
enforcement
in light of advice received from the
disabled persons transport advisory
committee minimum dimensions are still
prescribed for bays reserved for the
disabled bay holders as you previously
mentioned this must be a minimum of six
point six meters long and two point
seven meters wide
some of the issues that mr rate
has sometimes
one or two
uh
unauthorized vehicles par partly in the
space of each v
bay rendering it useless and this has
been previously mentioned at
meetings
mr ray has a large vehicle with a ramp
and needs the entire bay length
mr rate has been informed by both tdc
councillors and officers that as long as
less than half of an or unauthorized
vehicle i.e no blue badge
is in the bay tdc can take no action
uh that has previously been mentioned at
previous meetings
this is regardless of whether the
offending vehicle is a mini or a truck
the resident has been told by tdc such
cases will win on appeal so it is not
worth doing
so i'll ask officers to take note of
that
no evidence has so far been produced
that this policy
is in accordance with kcc or national
guidelines so if this is the case unless
they show otherwise
councillor binks
uh estimates that this originates within
fannie district council
tdc have a duty of care to the public
also with the regard to equality as
councillor whitehead mentioned
policy that enables an unauthorized
vehicle to park
in
parks such as it deprives a person
of of this disability from utilizing the
disabled parking bay could possibly be
in contravention of that duty and
intentions of the equality act
at such times the residency says he is
advised to phone tdc parking enforcement
team and he's encountered numerous
issues
he's had numerous problems getting
through to enforcement both during
normal working times but particularly
out of hours on on the evenings weekends
and holidays
mr rate was once actually put through to
a slow number via tdc's out of hours
service is there any out of hours
response in such circumstances if so
what is the number
in the report tdc now say enforcement
will only be on regular patrols on
residential areas there is no automatic
response to complaints
out of our service is only by email to
the civil enforcement team
the tdc website does not clearly state
which email it is
is it carparking at fanet.gov dot uk
uh and that that's me thank you
sorry can i come in because i was trying
i was trying to actually add to abby's
report but i didn't get an opportunity
to before your question so if i can just
add that may possibly answer some of
those questions um
so i think what we've heard today about
um the out of hours is something that we
could definitely take away and look at
we aren't a response service we're not a
999 we can't
guarantee that when people call we'll be
able to be there we just don't have that
ability um even
do i dare say this the police don't have
that ability so i think we need a bit of
um realist realism about what we can
provide in terms of an out of hours
service but absolutely it's the main
switchboard number um to to call when
that goes through to our service if
there are problems with our outbound
service that doesn't sit with us
unfortunately um but i know that there
has previous and i've responded to mr
ray around um something recently where
the calls weren't actually put through
to um
i think something has to flick a switch
so all of our calls go through to the
the out of our service and something
happened but it didn't work uh one
weekend unfortunately that's out of our
control um but yeah absolutely take that
back in terms of the out of hours and
what we can do
um but it won't be an instant response
service and i think that's something i
just needed to put across we don't have
that ability
unfortunately
grateful for your response thank you
thank you other members
council fellow
yeah thank you chad um just want to pick
up a couple of things that counselor
chro brown um i mean it's covered most
of things but um to do with this 50
parking in a base is this a tdc policy
that we don't
ticket cars or vehicles that are 50 in a
bag so i mean it has been spoke about at
the meetings before about this you know
and i think it was all about because
we'd lose on appeal apparently i don't
can we just confirm if this is our our
policy or
so it's it's not a policy and i'm we're
not entirely sure where this 50
has come from either so it's something
we're going to have to take away because
obviously i don't know whether you're
all aware that i am very new to parking
and and so so unfortunately is abby so
we are a bit kind of getting some of the
information tonight as well um it's
if you look at most parking uh
contraventions they have to be parked
which is the wheels into the bay
so that's what we would be looking at so
i don't know where the 50 has come from
um but we would be the definition that's
read out is exactly there that um it has
to be parked in the bay so we're looking
at parked so i'm not sure where 50 to
come from that's something that we will
clarify and we can put that into this as
well
so so
mr rate be um assured that
100 of uh enforcement officers will now
give tickets instead of 50 as he's
telling us
from from going forward
yeah we will we have already spoken to
enforcement officers about following on
from some complaints that we've been
dealing with recently so yeah absolutely
and also sorry one more thing um
can we do anything from photographic
evidence of a car parked in a space or
is that is that impossible
no unfortunately we need to witness it
in order to be able to do it we have to
be able to put it on the vehicle
all right council talks
do you have a map in your office of how
many parking baits you've got i probably
haven't and that's a certain you haven't
and it's a question
when we had a mobile library in ramsgate
cannon road we've got four disabled bays
there
never in my lifetime have four vehicles
turned up in that disabled bay i can't
remember why and i don't know why that
was ever put there because
the mobile library was the other end of
cannon road
so
look at that four souls out of walk from
there so anyway you've got those four
bays that are in your allocations that
are never used they're in canada
probably one out of four probably be
used there's not gonna be four people
turning up or disabled but i mean
maybe you could lose two of them and
allocate them somewhere else much needed
just just a thought
thank you for that i'd just say that we
we don't
sort of enforce on that area so as in we
don't say we've got a hundred bays we
can only force a hundred bays so it
doesn't matter how we've got so just
wanted to make that
council yates
thank you jeff um
yeah following on from the fellow
counsellors
it's been highlighted about an email
address um
i don't actually know what that email
address is either and i've i've just two
days ago sent an email about a parking
contravention
to car parking didn't get any response
um
so what is the official email address
please
so it is car.parking at vanit.gov dot uk
so you won't get a response driver i
think you get a bounce back that says
it's within a certain number of days if
it's gone to the correct address so yeah
that will be
yeah thanks for clarifying thanks
any other members
counselor scoby
what if you don't have access to email
then you can call us
and you can drop into the gateway i
believe as well sorry you can drop into
the gateway i believe as well our front
desk is open to take calls
okay thank you any other members
okay
thank you
[Music]
and talk through the whole issues
because not all of them have been
addressed and not all the concerns are
are there so i would like to see if
there's possible face-to-face to go
through
concerns
please
it appears you you may do that yeah
okay
thank you
thank you chair um so this is us
bringing forward the new proposals for
some new restrictions across the
district of planet we have provided
those in map form and these are in place
to assist with the flow of traffic and
access issues that may have been
experienced by residents and some
councillors and also kcc we've put a
mixture of where these requests have
come from these have all been visited
and investigated and these are the ones
that we are proposing that will then if
the board agrees take forward to public
consultation to add to the traffic
regulation order um so i will go to page
43 and just skip through um so we are
looking to
extend some double yellow lines on
belvedere road in broad stairs and
remove one permit bay so that there is a
resident who has a rear
gated access
that will be their driveway so we will
be looking to take that to consultation
so that
member can have access to their property
um we've got westover road and westover
gardens in broadstairs we're looking to
install
double yellow line corner protections
for
sight lines and pulling out onto the
road
um moving on to margate we've got
enterprise roads in margate we're
looking to add
um
again corner protection wla lines for
access for deliveries for large b and q
lorries that was a request from kent
county council
westbrook road and seaview terrace in
margate
we are looking to install a section of
willa lines to keep
gated access to a residence of charlotte
court clear problematic in the summer
being a seafront location and they are
having access getting to their parking
area
and then we have windham avenue in
margate again this will be a new
installation of double yellow lines
there is a small section of road between
two dropped cars and two forecourts
which if a vehicle parks overhangs both
sides causing access issues on each side
moving on to ramsgate we've got archway
road in ramsgate we're looking to extend
the wla lines on archbay road due to
access issues and obstruction issues
for residents in the area
we're also looking to extend double
lines on the cloisters in ramsgate again
due to access issues for residents and
waste disposal teams
and then we have got a number of double
yellow line
installations in the meridian village in
ramsgate which again is to ease access
issues for residents and they've also
been ex
experiencing issues with waste
collection so that is to ease all points
of access for residents and waste
disposal
lastly we've got some mildred road in
westgate
which is an extension to existing w
lines on a corner junction to improve
sight lines when pulling out the
junctions as a main road and due to
large vehicles parking this is quite
frequently obstructed so that's to
improve that so that just summarizes
what we're looking to take forward if
there's any questions
do you have any questions members
no questions
recommendation is that the subject
subject to the views of the board the
recommendations shown in appendix 1 are
approved
that the proposals which require
statutory consultation are advertised
that any traffic-related objections are
reported back to a future meeting of the
board
can i have a proposal please
cancer fellows
have a second to please
counsel crowbrow thank you
agenda item 8 is proposed disabled
persons parking places various roads
than it
i called upon miss young park
parking policy officer and juice report
i think i've just done that
was
it's like it's duplicated isn't it it's
very similar yeah thank you
thank you thank you chair so this
proposal um is just for the um
input of new disabled persons parking
places and all these locations listed
have already got interim bays and part
of the application process a small
consultation with direct neighbours has
been undertaken we are proposing to the
board um if in approval that these will
then be taken forward and added to our
traffic regulation order allowing them
to become enforceable base and so again
i will just run through the maps and
just to outline in broad stairs we have
um
outside 20 linden avenue
out
percy avenue outside number 61
and then moving to margate outside 14
dane road and outside 43 hastings avenue
outside 60 milton avenue
and outside 11 poets corner
we have got the outside one richmond
avenue
and outside three upper dame road and
also outside 24 windsor avenue so they
are all the ones for margate
moving on to ramsgate
we have got
a
installation outside 24 buxton road
we've got one outside three dane road
we've also got one outside nine dane
road we've got one outside 21 edith
court
we've got one outside 62 lorena road and
outside 17 queens avenue
and outside 21 royal road so that's the
ones that we propose for rams gates
moving on to west gates we have got one
outside 33 belmont road
outside 69 a c road and to the rear of
83a um sea road which will actually be
located the bay will be located on
westgate bay avenue so they are the ones
that we are proposing
to take forward
thank you
that the proposals which require
statutory consultation are advertised
and that any traffic related objections
are reported back to a future meeting of
the board
can i have a proposal please
councillor tonks and a second of these
council council yates thank you
agenda item 9 verbal update on public
consultations
i call upon miss button director of
neighborhoods to provide the update
thank you penny
and i'm quickly going to defer to abby
to reply the update
hello again you'll be bored of me um so
this is just to update the board on um
restrictions which have previously come
to the board and have been out to
consultation just to give you an update
with where we're at um so first of all
we did go out to consultation following
recommendation of the board to add some
off street caravan and motor caravan
parking places we're pleased to confirm
that there was only one comment received
for this um public consultation which
was in favor of the proposed changes
these are going ahead all costs have
been agreed via our fees and charges and
we anticipate this restriction to be
live for the first of april 2022 ready
for the summer season
this has been part of also a
consolidation of our off-street order
meaning we will have a consolidated
off-street traffic regulation order as
of the 1st of april 2022
the locations for which the campervan
parking will be available will be uh
five bays in minnesota birchington there
will be four bays in mildred's bay
westgate there will be five bays in
barns car park margate there will be
three bays in just bay car park
broadstairs and there will be four bays
in marina esplanade ramsgate so we have
tried to listen to the board's comments
and go out for seafront locations for
motor
caravans and caravans and there will be
a 10 pound charge for 24 hours of
parking
the second update is actually for our
on-street consolidation order
and that is um for consultation on
multiple double yellow lines in the
margot area and we also went out to
consultation for a no loading ban in
herbert place
firstly herbert place we received
received multiple comments from local
businesses
regarding large deliveries and how that
would impact the businesses so we are
going to amend this proposal to shorten
the length of the no loading ban to
allow space for a goods vehicle loading
bay these new proposals will be going
back out to public consultation and we
will report back to the board upon the
closure of that consultation
we also had a proposal to extend the
existing w lines in edgar road in
cliftonville margate we've received
multiple comments in objection to this
proposal we have abandoned the
extensions of the wl alliance as it's
going to cause detrimental effect to
local residents and in an already
difficult parking area and we are going
to leave the existing corner protections
as they are
and then all other proposals for double
yellow lines within this amendment have
will be going ahead and will be um going
out as a
live or live amendment to our order
later this year
thank you if you have any questions
thank you
remember us have any questions please
council fellows
sorry trevor thank you sir um
clarified one back to the um minnesota
you said five plays in munich's bay
british bay car park or
yeah
sorry yes sorry this is car park it's
all off street the first part for motor
caravans and caravans they are all car
parks so they will all be off street
and how does one get a ticket for 10
pounds
so it will be um as the methods are
already there so depending on location
it will either be by paying display
machine or via ringo and barnes car park
is a ringo only cashless payment zone so
you will only be able to purchase that
via um the ringo service but in all
other locations you will pay at the pay
display machine or you can use your
mobile phone
i said those machines i mean it's going
to be altered to so at certain times you
can only buy a campervan ticket for 10
pounds yeah
correct all changes are going ahead and
should be live on the 1st of april
thank you cancer talks there's a
question really
uh thanks for the update on the caravans
it is a big of a problem in ramsey it
has been made because a bit more sunny
and ramsay than most parts and that
some of the caravans that used to park
along the seafront now parking outside
the montefiore medical center
i don't know whether it's effective plus
you've got other businesses along there
but anyway i just wonder whether you can
help me out for many a year we've got
yellow lines along grange road
and casey seals before
nobody can actually back a lorry in and
to unload at londis they're on the
pavement you've got the flat side
opposite and they're there all day
can anybody just help them shops out
find out what they the delivery is
and make sure they enforce
no parking because some of them larry's
they're up on the pavement near there's
ever crossing just like it does
of course we can absolutely do that um
we
can get that added to the diaries for
regular patrols no problem
any other members
any more questions
okay this item is for information please
can members note this update that
concludes the business for the evening
thank you for your attendance
council
travel again kcc
now because we've got no counsellor a
kcc person here all my rafter issues who
can i pass it on to because i'm here on
other people's behalf i mean we got
parking problems at um
nicholas
and abby gail abby smith from there and
i said well i'm at the meeting tonight
so i've got a whole lot of vision and i
actually been to kcc at highways at
sandwich so am i wasting my time
because we're casey's here we're trying
to do what the people elected us for
and
i look at that person on the zoom
meeting a lot of issues and now we're
not responsible for this tdc no we're
not that's kcc
so
i'm lost i'm not in space now what can i
do with all my concerns
why isn't here
i didn't explain i'd explain the reason
why my paul barrett wasn't here
anyway we have actually concluded this
meeting now so
good evening everybody and thank you
very much
you